we're going to begin with an alarming
sign of rising tensions between North
and South Korea developments over the
past 12 hours the north has fired nearly
two dozen missiles into the sea around
the Korean Peninsula according to
officials in South Korea and Japan one
of those missiles flashed down in an
area that is supposed to be and was
until now a no fire zone South Korea
responded with its own missile test
while a continued joint military
exercises with the U.S Elizabeth Palmer
has more now from Tokyo Elizabeth good
morning
good morning we've seen an unprecedented
number of North Korean missile launches
this year but today's was unusually
aggressive
South Koreans watched the news that one
more time their neighbor was firing
weapons in their Direction and this time
far too close for comfort one missile
flew South and actually crossed the
informal Maritime border it landed in
the sea just 37 miles from the South
Korean city of sokcho the other flew
near the island of ulong do near enough
to activate Air Raid Sirens
and warn people to seek shelter all week
U.S and South Korean war planes have
been flying joint drills the latest in a
series of military exercises that have
infuriated North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un today he retaliated with
multiple missile launches and in turn
South Korea fired three air-to-ground
missiles of its own northward in a
dangerous tip for Taft
lists in my diplomatic sources say that
there's no reason to think tension on
the Korean Peninsula is going to
diminish anytime soon in fact just the
opposite they expect that North Korea
may escalate with an underground nuclear
weapons test sometime quite soon Gail
thank you Elizabeth reporting from Tokyo